Này 2020 tháng 3 năm, một người chiến trăm 1 năm, chú tịch OChimin chữ tập cuộc họp của Iban zân tập sẽ phẩm.
Chó khu khọt này, người đã đề nghỉ thì hành chính xác loàn kết giộng giải,
thành lập chính phủ thông nhất cút ra, bao gồm cả những đại biểu các đảng phái yếu nước,
và những nhân sĩ khục phải đảng phái có dành vào.
Đến nghỉ cũng người được mọi người tán thành.
Nhiều bị viên Việt mình từ người ảnh sinh suốt lôi, để nhường chủ ở trần những người khác thục đảng phái khác.
Chú tịch OChimin được bầu, làm chú tịch chính phủ lâm thời nước Việt Nam dân chủ cộng hoa.
Chẳng chính phủ có bác giế cho đảng dân chủ một tông giáo và nhiều bộ trường không đảng phái.
Cũng trong ngày này, cuộc tộc khình nghĩa tiếp tục diễn ra ở các biểu quyền và dành tháng lợi như rời giá, châu đốc, biền hoa.
Các cuộc khởi nghĩa này, tiếp tục là ngôn cộng gũ động viên cho các biểu quyền khác nổi dậy, dành chính quyền những ngày tiếp theo.